testing one two testing this meeting
foreign
everybody
we'll begin our meeting this morning in
our usual fashion by all rising and
joining representative Corman as he
so this morning we're here to have one
public hearing
scheduled for 9 A.M
a public hearing on HB
556--fm relative to the duties of the
information Technology Council
and as soon as we complete that public
hearing we will move on to an executive
session in which we will hear
or adjudicate
11 bills 11 or 12. I've forgotten 11 or
12 bills that are listed in the house
calendar
so with that I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 556 and call to
the front of the room the prime sponsor
of the bill representative
Eric Gallagher of Concord welcome
representative
so hello uh for the record I am
representative Eric Gallagher uh from
Concord Ward six that's Merrimack County
District 20 and I am here to introduce
house bill
556 relative to the duties of the
information Technology Council
so
this bill is was part of
um one of the bills
I filed last year
um
so last year I filed
House Bill 1273 which I also referred to
as my software act which was an acronym
for securing our freedom to write and
read everything
so
yeah this bill is
based on feedback I got from that bill
so
um
yeah basically the idea of it is to
promote software freedom in the state of
New Hampshire that is
being able to do with your computers As
You Wish rather than having
um
big tech companies
control you
um
so
the feedback part one of the items of
feedback was that I was trying to do too
much in a single bill
um this it went before Edna by the way
so this is their feedback so yeah I
split it up this was the part of the
bill that was the study committee
portion of it basically just studying
how we can
um
make greater use of free software as
free us and freedom here in the state
um
another part of the feedback was all
right why is this coming before eena
instead of Science and Technology and I
mean I I don't really know how Bill's
got assigned but
um
this year by breaking it into multiple
pieces I did manage to get at least this
one before this committee so
um hopefully that's an improvement
um and then another one was why are you
creating a new study committee when we
already have this information Technology
Council
um so yeah I
took basically the duties of
the previous bills
study committee and um just assigned
them to the existing information
technology
uh Council instead
so
um to
go over the
um
so to go over the uh
bullet points um
so
replacing proprietary software used by
CA agencies proprietary software is
basically
the opposite of free and open source
software
um
it basically
gives tech companies leverage over us
um
and
uh there there is bipartisan anger at
big Tech from the right for
things like censorship and from the left
for just being big in general
um
so yeah I think
that if we
can figure out a way
to reduce or
remove entirely our use of proprietary
software we can
um
gain some power back from the big Temp
Tech companies
um
so then also there's a point about
artificial intelligence in there that's
something that's becoming a Hot Topic
that I think as a state we need to start
thinking about
um
so copy left licensees that's a specific
type of free and open source software
um
bit which basically
it's form of copyright but instead of
granting exclusive rights
um like proprietary software does it
requires
uh
people that use and redistribute
copyleft software to preserve those same
freedoms
to in any further redistributions
um
so State's ability to
develop and release open source software
that means writing software itself as
opposed to the previous one where it's
about using other people's free and open
source software
um
consider how to develop a program and
funding mechanism for providing legal
assistance to developers of free
software that that has to do with one of
the
one complaint I hear from free software
developers a lot as to
uh why they don't use copyleft licenses
as well oh it's gonna be too much of an
effort for me to defend it in court
um so I think
um having making it easier
for free software developers to do that
would help encourage the development of
more of it
um
so
review and develop recommendations for
the expansion of the Statewide
information policy on open government
data standards so
that's basically just like what file
formats things are in
and then
attack enact adopt and Implement when
feasible and policy to ensure the right
to data portability so that's one of the
things Europe's gdpr
um address the p in this reportability
basically
being able to
take your Computing data from one
service to another rather than having
the company that runs the service
control whether you can do that or not
so um that one that's what that one's
about so this is all um
this is all advisory
um the
the uh
advice is
can certainly be ignored if the
information technology ends up giving
bad advice
um so yeah I think
that makes it a pretty good substitute
for a study committee and I'll take any
thank you before I call on
representative Thomas to ask a question
I need to ask a question myself
and that is when you use the word free
in this legislation you mean free to
inspect
uh
and transparent but you don't
necessarily mean free of cost is that
correct uh yes correct um in the free
software World sometimes that's referred
to as the Libre versus Gratis
distinction
um just due to other languages have that
distinction where Libre means free Us in
Freedom
um and then Gratis means free asking
costs sometimes you have software that
is both Libre and Gratis but it doesn't
necessarily have to be the case there
are actually some companies that sell
Libre software like red hat for instance
um
and meanwhile there's also lots of
Gratis software that is not Libre so
yeah I mean um
I mean primarily uh Libre software
thank you for that clarification
representative Thomas has a question
that's Doug Thomas that is thank you
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um
comment first uh it's interesting that
this came to us I was going to recommend
that it go to Commerce for our review
but that's the one committee we have it
here that's the one committee that I
haven't got well actually they got right
to repair which wasn't originally part
of this bill but is kind of related but
they're the one committee that yeah the
um last year's bill got broken up so it
went to e-dna Judiciary criminal justice
and this committee but not Commerce
though so so my my question is since we
already have an Information Technology
Council I I don't see why explain to me
why these items could not have just been
presented to the council in a matter of
an agenda item instead of having a whole
new bill and repurposing the uh the uh
the it Council why why couldn't these
things be discussed in the Council just
as a part of a normal agenda item I mean
I guess theoretically they could be but
if you look at the RSA being amended
here it has a bunch of other items on
there already that could also just be
agenda items
um about strategic technology plans uh
computer systems consolidation uh so I
think basically this is just meant to
fit in with the existing items and
follow-up
uh
do with these if these things were added
would there be would there be need for
additional people to be placed on the
council for expanded knowledge purposes
um
the
the legislation does not specify a
number of or well at least the RSA being
amended here does not specify the number
of members so
um
I mean yeah I'm not touching that so I
would assume that it would continue to
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Gallagher for taking my
question
can you provide us some examples of some
of the state systems that would be
appropriate to transition from
proprietary to free or open source
um
so
yeah uh
I mean I think like
using Libra office instead of Microsoft
Office for example would be one um
for uh GIS
um I know like my dad makes maps for the
state
um and
um
apparently uh the planning office pays
out a lot of money to
um
esri every year when
um previously it did actually use grass
GIS which is a
free alternative to it
which I think could be returned to
um
uh some of my other bills focused more
on user facing ones such as
um
such as like the websites or things that
people enter inter citizens interact
with
um
for like paying taxes or filing for
assistance programs with uh
with
DHHS for example
um
and there there have been stories
one of our local
town or town libraries actually
transitioned their entire Library
software to be free and open source um
and
so I mean we have a state Library so I
think they could
take some
inspiration from
the town that did that I can't remember
which one it was off the top of my head
um
but yeah there's a lot of examples and
there are in fact a lot of places where
um the state does already use free and
open source software like at one of the
previous hearings
um
that commissioner was telling about how
a lot of the websites run on Drupal so
that
is something that's good that I think
could be done more of um
representative berezny how to build that
I co-sponsored last term
that was also kind of along these lines
so yeah I think this bill
could
um help identify some additional ways to
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
representative for being here
um this is um very interesting ideas in
this bill and I believe you're the first
one to bring up the ethics of our
artificial intelligence so that's kind
of interesting
um my concern in this sort of piggybacks
on what representative Doug Thomas said
was do you believe the counts you're
requiring some pretty intense new
studies to be added to this report and I
don't know if it's a yearly report or
not but do you believe the council has
the skills and the resources to add on
all of these more complex studies
um
I think yeah fear well so my original
idea was to make
a new study committee
because Edna was wondering why make a
new study committee when the information
Technology Council already exists if it
turns out that we do actually need an
entirely new study committee event yeah
I'd be fine with switching back to that
with making it a separate committee
after all I was just
um pending list to the information
Technology Council specifically based on
feedback from Edna last term
thank you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question now myself being a
former paid hacker I have to ask you a
question about open source
um
knowing that uh in open source and
freeware it's pretty common that we used
to back in the days of bash open BSD and
that we used to live in that world and
we'd be able to would this not make it
easier for folks to be able to
manipulate the kernel change the change
the clock speed and be able to
manipulate software that's open to
everybody
um
so
well it it depends on the people you're
talking about specifically
yes it would make it easier
for
people in the state government who we
want to actually be doing that but free
software it does come with access
controls and security features
um you know being open source lets it be
inspected by
a large number of people to
um
so that means that it uh vulnerabilities
are disclosed more quickly
um in
previous hearings for example the log
for J vulnerability was brought up which
was kind of portrayed as a failing of
Open Source but I actually see that as a
successive open source since the
vulnerability was actually disclosed
rather than just going undisclosed for a
long period of time where nobody knows
if it's being exploited or not whereas
this actually let it get fixed a lot
uh yeah just a random person who knows
that was able to fix it
um so and yeah I'd also remind people of
the distinction between code and data
um
so
yeah
so uh
software that is open source can be used
with data that is private there there is
a distinction there
um and yeah you see
you know there's examples like the gnu
privacy guard
for example is and
um
a piece of software that can help
protect your privacy
data privacy so
um but yeah that is something
that this
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um also wanted to say thank you for
bringing this bill it's nice to actually
deal with some technology on the sdne
committee
um I was just wondering getting to the
ethics of artificial intelligence usage
um
can you give some examples of places
where State agencies maybe are looking
at using AI or are already using AI do
you know if anyone's using like chat GPT
to create things Etc
um
so no I don't know
if they are currently but there are lots
of applications where
um
where they could be
um yeah like chat GPT I used that to
um
help prepare for
uh some of my I I asked it about some of
my own bills that I was introducing to
see uh what it thought of them not not
this one specifically but other ones um
yeah um stuff like stable diffusion or
dolly for artwork Generation
Um you know for
if if we need to modify our logo or
provide
graphics for like there's a State Office
of graphics and printing that I walk by
pretty often on my walk to the lob here
um
so yeah like whether or not it would be
were there allowed to use that
um then also you get to stuff like
facial recognition
um in the
Criminal Justice field whether that
should be allowed
um that's a form of AI and then also AIA
based uh gunshot detections and you see
some police departments
I'm starting to use robots
uh for law enforcement
so there's a question there as to like
what sort of autonomy do we want to
Grant police robots that I think is
worth
seeing no further questions I want to
thank you representative for introducing
this proposed legislation
and I'd like now to call on Mr Dennis
Goulet who is the commissioner of the
Department of Information Technology Mr
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Dennis Goulet has
stated I am the commissioner for the
Department of Information Technology as
such I'm responsible for
um
operating the I.T function for the
executive branch in New Hampshire and I
am a member on the I.T Council
the uh a small correction uh the the I.T
Council membership is actually
documented in statute 21r and um so we
we do change it from time to time but
I've been here almost eight years now
it's been pretty stable
um and it is a mixture of agency folks
as well as outside influencers from
Education City Government town
government County Government
uh we we operate in an attempt to guide
the I.T I call it the board of directors
for my department and we like to have an
idea that we're fully transparent and
that we actually operate under best
practice for the i t function
for the executive branch we also
collaborate closely with the other
branches of government so you'll see a
lot of times we're actually doing the
same things
I'm testifying in opposition to this
bill this morning for three primary
reasons uh one is that actually the
subparts
um
I A9 i810 and I F really are already
covered under language in in the
information Technology Council and we
can all already execute on things like
that in fact we do consider
um I'll just give you an example a
representative Gallagher brought it up
when we were talking some years ago
about our new web what our new website
platform should be for for the state
um we were looking at all kinds of
options and we ended up
um in in deliberation with the
information Technology Council settling
on an open source a managed open source
platform that we now use and are
operating uh most of our executive
branch websites on as well as the
judicial branch website and the
Secretary of State super cost effective
works really well for us so you know we
do already consider open source and
we're running it in various other places
in fact the most recent thing is is for
our small agencies we have they have a
real challenge with costs right they
don't have a lot of money A lot of times
they're General funded so we're trying
to make sure we're spending the least
amount of money for them and and we're
going to do a pilot on on an open source
case management platform to see if that
would be a good fit for the small
agencies
uh the second reason why why uh area of
concern is the council is really not uh
currently empowered or provisioned to
take on some of these new duties as
defined in subparts uh IB through e and
IG
um it this would really reinvent our
focus and shift us outside of our you
know best practice for the executive
branch IET function
proposed subparts i c i d and I E
um really appear to take and direct the
council to a specific policy position
which I believe is outside of our peer
review and may actually not um
not be uh guide us towards Beck's
practice in each case
so best practice evolves over time
putting detailed I.T policy positions in
statute that then myself and my
successors have to follow I don't think
is in the best interest of the executive
branch or even the state as a whole
a couple other questions came up or at
least one other and that was
um
the the uh are there examples where it
might be good to run an open source
software for the state and I think I
touched on that a little bit but um you
know we we do have
um you know we are running
um our primary server operating system
is Linux we run a managed Linux so that
we're watching out for um making sure
we're fully patched at all times we have
over a thousand Linux servers running
applications just for the executive
branch and you know just the the
the effort of making sure we're patching
them for security and privacy of
information is is a large effort but it
does run really well for us so I again
I would uh again example of how we are
using open source and we are considering
it when uh when appropriate the log 4J
came up I thought
um I appreciate the question related to
security I think that any you know open
source or proprietary software can be
managed in a secure way or in an
insecure way I don't know that either
one of those platforms is particularly
less secure than the other it's all
about how you manage the code base and
manage the installed base the log4j
example the some incorrect information
was shared
and that is that that vulnerability was
out there for a long time years and
years and years and and it's taking us
actually years to remediate it because
it managed to get its that that Library
managed to get into lots of platforms
both both open source and proprietary
platforms so to the to this day I'm
still you know years after that popped
I'm Still Still managing it
the final thing is before I take as many
questions as you have is around
artificial intelligence it is rearing
its head now and I think that you know
I'd like to to contrast between what I
think the I.T council's duty is as it
relates to artificial intelligence and
and general public policy Duty so is
artificial intelligence a good way to
run I.T in New Hampshire from an I.T
perspective that is absolutely the I.T
council's responsibility I think we
should look at it and say what we're
doing and say whether we think it's a
good thing or not then there's is uh is
AI or robotic process automation a good
thing for the state the citizens of the
state the citizens of our country that
is not the purview of the information
Technology Council that's a larger
public policy issue that should be taken
up elsewhere
we do have some examples we're
considering now and we're considering a
remote process automation pilot soon
um why are we doing that we're having a
hard time hiring people and there's
certain types of jobs that it's really
good for is that is that the right thing
to do I'm not I'm not making that
distinction I'm I'm saying we may have
areas where we can mitigate the fact
that we can't hire people using RPI that
concludes my formal testimony and I have
I'll take questions excellent thank you
for that testimony representative Doug
Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question and um
it's good to see you here again you
don't come here very often so it's good
to see you now once in a while
um so
this poses a kind of a good question
here if there's a distinction between
the information Technology Council and
the information technology department
my question would be on what you see in
the spill which all seem to be good
ideas of things that should be
considered who if if not you or the
council who who do you believe should be
looking at these things at at the state
level
um you know I didn't prepare for that
question so you you got me you got me on
that one I I I'd be happy to cogitate on
that and look at each one individually
and give you a written answer uh that I
think that would be more appropriate
since I didn't spend any time thinking
about it thank you it would be good
thank you
representative McWilliams has a question
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
testifying in front of us this morning I
am intrigued by the possibility of AI in
terms of possibly helping out where we
don't have the Staffing and also um you
know setting some guard rails for future
use of AI by the state how do you see
that being reviewed and considered and
how do you see that playing out in the
next five years
well it's you know with the with the uh
massive acceleration of public
understanding that the AI functions the
chat gbt was brought up earlier
um we're now um that's going to be an
agenda item on our next it council
meeting and we're going to be talking
about what we know and what we don't
know but it's a national policy issue my
peers there's a body called the National
Association of State Chief Information
officers and I will tell you that we're
we are caught a little flat-footed at
the moment with the the massive
acceleration from that perspective but
we've already been using AI in other
areas of states and New Hampshire did
this where we you know taking you know
your traditional FAQ
in creating a smart chat bot that that
then adapt that you adapt over time so
that it actually gives better answers
we're honestly not very good at that
because it requires it's not just
technology it's like um when social
media first came out and business
entities or public policy entities want
to start engaging on social media they
said all right we'll just put something
up there and let it go and you can't do
that so AI you know whether it's a chat
bot or or a robotic process automation
needs people watching it you can't just
put it out there and let it run a couple
reasons one is you know you can keep
making it better with little tweaks you
can watch some of them some of it's very
well instrumented and you can keep an
eye on it and make it better and and
that's our job isn't it you know if
we're trying to serve the citizens we
want to focus on what we're doing and
try to make it better the other thing is
you can have some real unintended
consequences which you're not going to
find out
quickly enough if you're not paying
attention so we will be bringing that up
at our next it council meeting we will
be piloting some RPI in in for those
folks who are we have some you know
Innovative folks in the state that want
to try it out to help solve their
problems and we'll do some piloting of
representative brazny has a question
uh thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh if I heard
correctly when you listed the things
that you don't think um are should be
the duty of the console
um you said B through e and then
um G but I think you you didn't say f is
do you think that f is okay for um
actually f is already I feel f is
already covered under the duties of the
council okay and then I have a follow-up
question yes follow-up
um so uh for number nine under a
uh is zero would you be acceptable to
changing this
um to something else that's similar but
more acceptable or do you have feedback
more feedback on number nine there all
right being the potential cost and
feasibility of replacing all
proprietary software okay you're
referring to that yes okay so I did a I
did model
um House Bill 617 I think it is I did do
a cost model for that
um it's very you know the the
one of the challenges with with propriet
proprietary software versus open source
software in the government space is
there isn't a large market for what we
do so there isn't um a huge huge
companies doing these functions like
driver license system things like that
so what we'd end up doing in in that
case if we said all right we're going to
do everything or as much as possible
with open source I'd have a massive
development team you know so when
considering that I thought okay well if
we're going to do everything open source
we have to do it in a way that's secure
and private and also federally compliant
which is a huge deal because we accept a
lot of federal funds and we get audited
on that and there's certain there's
requirements for software life cycle
maintenance and and things like that so
we could absolutely do it be very
expensive because I'd be developing and
and the time to Value would be much
slower in many cases because if if
there's
software out there that can do something
like I know I can go out today and buy
permitting software that's 85 percent of
the way ready for me to use and serving
our citizens and businesses in the state
um you know I wouldn't I wouldn't have
the ability to do that in open source
context and I'd have to have a
development team build that for us so
uh I think we already do a lot of this
we look at all right
when we go out to procure we don't say
I'm going to buy open source software or
I'm going to buy proprietary software we
procure what solves our business problem
in the most cost effective way which I
think is the appropriate way to look at
technology technology is not it's not an
end in itself the business priorities
that are our citizen service business
priorities are the end
that's how we should Define our mission
that's how we should procure technology
thank you for coming today
um this is more of a general question
um in light of how our other state
agencies are sometimes managed how well
can you uh investigate such things as AI
and other Innovations without any type
of legislative directive
well we
all of the contracts in the executive
branch
come before me
for approval so I I actually I know
what's going on I know what we're
acquiring we have it doit staff roughly
half of my staff
um which is
370 authorized positions he's sitting
inside agencies working directly with
the agency so we actually know what's
going on in the agencies we work very
closely with them
um that team who's embedded and we also
talk to each other we have regular meet
weekly meetings where all of the heads
of I.T for each agency get together and
speak so I I feel like if if and the AI
stuff was was
done at my initiation so what I said is
okay let's how do we innovate here and
what agency needs it the most and is is
psychologically oriented to trying out
new things so so I feel like we're in in
decent shape there there's a lot of
challenges we do have that's not one of
our biggest ones though
follow-up
yes thank you chair
um so I gather now that your much of
your work is being driven from the base
up and I think it's laudable
um still I will ask again to take a look
at innovative
aspects that are not quite part of
what's being driven from the bottom such
things as Ai and chat GDP whatever it is
um things like this uh are you do you
feel like you're permitted to take
initiative to investigate these areas or
do you need legislation to direct you
and to investigate these more oh I I
understand your question better now I
apologize for not answering it the first
time
uh I feel like we have uh the
um 21r as as exists today empowers us to
do that and we do that all the time
and sometimes the you know the
Innovation comes from us thinking about
it in doit other times it comes from the
agencies who who who through their own
research have found something
interesting that they that they want to
try
before I call on representative muns for
a question I want to let everyone who is
observing this meeting know that an
executive session will begin at the
conclusion of this public hearing
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question
um are you aware of any states that have
adopted what this bill is recommending
going with all all uh free software
uh no in fact I I spent almost two years
as the president of the National
Association of Chief Information
officers so I'm pretty familiar with
what's going on around the country in
addition to the fact that I've been
you know I've been doing this for eight
years which turns out to be a long time
in my business I'm the third most
tenured State CIO and I have not seen
thank you representative Corman has a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
if systems were to transition from
proprietary software produced by
companies that are actually trying to
make money and keep users happy to free
and open source are you concerned about
support issues
uh you know if there's a question that
that somebody in state government has
who they gonna call
yes um in fact the the the
maintenance and support
um for if you know for free and open
source it's one of the reasons why for
example our websites even they're
running on Drupal but they're not
managed by us I have a third-party
company who manages that instance make
sure they're patching it make sure
they're keeping it up to date what what
we see in other states and we had a
question about what other states are
doing other states a lot of them are
using open source for their website
platforms and the number one reason uh
for website State website defacement is
the fact that it they put it out there
and forget about it and then don't patch
it because they don't have the staff to
do so so one of the things you have to
look at is is it goes back to my
statement earlier about any software can
be run securely or not depending on how
how well you manage it so I I believe
that you know for example we we run our
learning management system is open
source and it works really well in some
cases but I have to stay very focused on
managing that and I have staff who does
that
um which is not necessarily typical if I
were you know if I have a uh you know a
managed
um proprietary or managed open source
scenario so in the case of the learning
management system We Own It We own
patching it we own keeping it updated we
own can you know configuring it things
like that so it is definitely more of a
burden in that respect and I'll go a
little further and say support model is
something we think really hard about for
each and every technology we acquire so
it's not about buying this the software
or the technology per se that's the
smallest part of the cost
the the largest part of the cost is
implementing and managing over time in
an effective way so when we're looking
at when I'm looking at a procurement
that's coming across my desk and whether
I should sign off on it for technology
I'm looking at
has the support model been thought
through are we going to have make sure
that we're securing the data for our
citizens uh things like that so we
actually do have our chief information
security officer reviews every single
contract and we kick it back if we're
not satisfied with how that how the the
it's going to be managed and how the
data is going to be protected
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um unfortunately I guess I wasn't paying
as close attention as representative
brezhny but you did mention um that
there are a few elements in this bill
that you feel like you're already
covering
um on the I.T Council
um
I guess in your perspective would there
be harm in adding it to statute to
ensure that that was clear that that's
part of the council's responsibility
um or would that restrict you in some
way I I don't think it's necessary it's
already I think the the
the verbiage as it exists or the
language as it exists already empowers
you know further questions I want to
thank you for being here to uh give us
your perspective on this proposed
legislation for the opportunity I do
have one actually I do have one other
question
the department of the legislative budget
assistant was charged with producing the
fiscal note for this bill and they
consulted you and there was no time to
produce one have you provided an updated
fiscal note to the house clerk yep I did
um uh I think it was a couple weeks ago
we finished it initially the the process
went we I was asked for a fiscal note I
sent one in they questioned the the
um some of my assumptions which I then
clarified and so there I did see in
language that that my fiscal information
is in the current language that's on the
website right now
okay thank you very much you're welcome
so next I'll call on our final
uh presenter for this bill Dennis
Goddard of Hopkinton representing
uh thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee my name is Dennis Goddard and
I'm here of course um purely
representing my own personal opinions
um on the legislation but it's relevant
um for you to know
um these opinions are sort of informed
by
um
my position as a director of development
and operations at Oracle Corporation the
world's largest database company
specifically I'm employed in the
autonomous database division which is
that division which is charged with
figuring out ways to more
usefully uh marry artificial
intelligence in large database
technology
so
I think
at the end of the day I'm in support of
this legislation
all of the issues listed here are issues
that just we as a society as a
civilization
are going to have to deal with are
presently dealing with
and desperately need our public
institutions to be looking at and some
of these are hard
are and I've been in a number of
companies and organizations that have
had to deal with some of these specific
enumerated issues how are we going to
deal with open source this was a huge
problem for us proprietary companies
especially about 20 years ago when it
got fashionable for some of us employed
in large companies to start coding free
stuff on our free time
um
because these things are difficult as a
society to talk about I think it's going
to be nest because it's easy for
organizations not to deal with difficult
complex challenging
intellectual problems
um I think these specific things do need
to be enumerated and there needs to be
some accountability and we need the
public institutions in particular
um Information Technology Council to be
looking at these issues and and give us
the public
um
some some clarity and some information
back
um
it's not clear to me as a non-expert in
our state government whether the
information technology is the
group that needs to look at these issues
but it is absolutely a
um
I want to speak uh very oh and I want to
speak very briefly to a couple of points
made by the commissioner I I sort of
heard two things
um both on the one hand there are things
that we already do and on the other hand
things that we
ought not to look at I would say that
those things that are already
being looked at that is great that is
very very good and we need to depend on
more than oral tradition and
institutional knowledge to keep that up
we need that clarified and we need some
accountability that we as the public are
going to get some some clarity on
certain of these things and no for sure
um that the council is is examining
these issues as for the things that it's
asserted it possibly ought not to do
these are very large things I you know
okay real briefly a little bit more
about my personal life I was doing AI
before it was cool
um back in 1992 you can look this up
um I trained a neural network using
Intel 486s which was the best that we
had at the time he had a bank of them
back at the University right
um it was UW-Madison I could train it to
do like letter recognition like you
could draw letters not mind your own
network could could recognize those
um
but it's really and and so when this
sort of artificial intelligence
discussion just a couple years ago uh
Stephen Hawking before he died suddenly
came out and said you know AI is the
biggest threat to humanity or something
like that and I just thought how
overblown this guy's gonna pass to speak
um but in the last two or three years
um I've come to realize that perhaps
um well it's been said and I I no longer
think this is exaggeration
that artificial intelligence poses more
of a change to our society than the
internet
did possibly more than electricity
it is necessary for our public
institutions to be examining not just
that but even in a more um immediate
sense open source and the two things are
ethically related and we need individual
uh public bodies particularly a
Technology Council to be looking at them
uh so very very briefly on
um I just want to mention that support
has been mentioned
um again largest database company in the
world so many of our customers run their
databases on Linux
um the majority of our developers do
their work on Linux and not just Oracle
IBM uh Red Hat lots and lots of really
big companies really very happy to sell
you or any other uh government uh
contracts for support and development
including of Open Source stuff though I
can't speak I'm not a Salesman for for
my company
um
oh and I I do have to apologize I
I I have to take a little bit of umbrage
I heard it mentioned by a member
something about the old days and Bash I
do spend the majority of my waking and
working Life In The Bash shell and it's
a beautiful place to live and I will
okay questions for Mr Goddard very
interesting point of view I appreciate
you
being here to offer it to us
one question from representative
barashni thank you chairman and thank
you for taking my question so you
mentioned several times that you think
that we should be talking about these
issues
um it's a little hard to say just
talking about him without having sort of
an end product or or kind of a
conclusion that we should reach can you
elaborate on what you think like if if
there was a committee or commission that
had the end result what would those
bullet points be thank you oh I I
believe that they're explicitly laid out
uh in both the bill and the existing
legislation we're looking for direction
and advice like advise the commissioner
on
what are we doing about copyleft what
are the ethics as the council sees them
on the use of artificial intelligence
where and how and how is it applicable
um that that doesn't necessarily mean
creating law or or a policy but it it
does mean well but perhaps a policy
advice to the commissioner
um
advice perhaps back to the legislative
body certainly I would see a council as
being a better tool for some of these
fast-moving things then look if we don't
do this in the format of a council that
can act in a more expeditious manner
we're going to have to be dealing with
these things reactively each and
individually in kind of legislation in
response to what do we do when we find
that people using GPT have
the Lord knows done what to our to our
Democratic processes are
consensus on what's real
um now these are areas where I believe
they are our commissioner and our our
legislators uh and our executive uh
require uh some some unified
um uh message back just as they
presently are on things like how are we
going to use information technology
generally how do we consolidate our
systems generally
which are already in the legislature are
already in past legislation
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here and for taking my question
when I think about AI in state agencies
or in general one of the concerns that
comes up is bias
and bias can come certainly from
training data
but it can also be reinforced by the
software itself and I'm just wondering
what what are your thoughts on where
what what are the sources of bias and
what can be done about it my thoughts
are that we are in the Stone Age when it
comes to AI I do talk to
um
academics and individuals whose job it
is to keep on the absolute Cutting Edge
of AI which at this point as an amateur
AI follower I can't do anymore it
changes so much every six months so much
stuff is coming up and as a tech guy
that is saying something
um
sorry I almost lost a threat on that
with respect to bias when I talk to
these experts the best things that we
have that are come up with are things
like if you don't want it to know about
pornography don't show it pornography
and then it won't be able to generate
pornography and that's the best that we
can do really and that yeah is the best
that we can do right now really these
are largely what they call black boxes
they're um there is a burgeoning science
of explainable AI but that's very
limited and most of what a AI stuff is
actually out there is you know we
trained it we don't really understand
exactly how it works how it comes up
with certain biases a fascinating topic
is hacking AI where you classical
example a clear and obvious picture of
say a dog you ask the thing is this a
cat or a dog uh or or what is the what
is this object comes up with the dog by
altering a few pixels in a way that a
human would never notice you can push
the thing because it's in a very high
dimensional space two points that don't
appear to be close together in a higher
Dimension can be Boom the thing oh it's
a fire hydrant absolutely guaranteed
fire hydrant 99 accuracy fire hydrant
right
um so where these buy and that's that's
the kind of bias right where these
biases come from how to manipulate them
we're only in the Stone Age of being
able to figure out how it happens
um
anyone that tells you otherwise is
representative munz ask a question thank
you Mr chair and um thank you for
testifying this has been fascinating and
you've certainly opened my mind
um are there other other
issues that we should be addressing that
aren't included in this bill that we
should include probably and too numerous
to mention and appearing too fast to
absorb as a society I would view this
bill as in a very important I think we
have consensus
um generally about these particular
things being things that in general are
in the Zeitgeist we know that open
source is a thing we know that
copyrights and how large tech companies
interface with individuals and our data
um
and how AI is going to play into all of
this ethically
I think this is a good base to start
from
okay seeing no other questions I thank
you for being here today to give us your
perspective on this proposed legislation
and with no more pink cards in hand I
will close the public hearing on House
Bill 556 and do we have any blue sheet
information
uh thank you chair yes uh House Bill 556
the blue sheet none in support one
opposed
online
three in support
okay thank you
it is now time to move to the second
part of our activity for the day
and
by opening an executive session on House
Bill 159 relative to the default service
rate for electricity and the chair
recognizes representative Doug Thomas
for a motion well actually before I
recognize
representative Doug Thomas
I'm going to explain something that I
had a discussion with the ranking member
I was given information from the clerk
about
the process for coming up with an a
recommendation from the committee of
without recommendation
as it turns out
the information I was given earlier
about voting on all three possible
States
OTP itl and retain
is true but only if the Motions are made
so if emotion is made
and the resulting vote is 10 10.
if no additional emotions are made then
the bill comes out of committee without
recommendation
so going through the process of voting
for The Other motions
which will both come out 10 10 anyway
doesn't have to be done
we can simply vote on one motion if it
comes out 10 10
restrain ourselves discipline ourselves
to make no further motions
and we're done
so with that explanation explanation I
will now recognize Mr chair Doug Thomas
for a motion on House Bill 159 sure just
have a question oh okay question from
representative muns one of the things
I've been struggling with over the
weekend and I probably should know this
but uh humor me
um if we if we vote to retain the bill
does it go to the floor
no okay retain means keep it within the
committee okay
so that might be the only time
if we voted if it was a 10-10 vote
we still might want to do a motion to
retain because there may be some
some thoughts on whether it makes sense
or not correct thank you thank you
all right see no further questions I'll
recognize representative Thomas for a
motion on House Bill 159. thank you Mr
chair of the motion uh for HP 159 is to
retain
recognize representative Bernardi the
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we retain House Bill 159
representative Thomas is recognized
uh yes uh quite simply there is a PC
docket underway covering the subject and
it would be best to wait and see what
comes out of that docket and then we can
take it up later in the fall uh on the
retained uh basis
further discussion on the motion
representative McWilliams oh thank you
chair Vos
um this is a really important topic to
our constituents in regards to peaks
with electric bills and I think that it
would be worthy of a subcommittee so I
would be happy to serve on a
subcommittee to look at this while it is
being retained so we can bring it back
thank you representative McWilliams I
think a subcommittee would be justified
for this bill
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman would you mind introducing the
guests that we have on the committee
today
yes so
representative Larry gagne is here today
for Michael Harrington
representative Charlie Melvin is here
for representative lewicki
and Carol Brown
and representative Linda Ryan is here
for representative Kaplan and
representative Rose Marie wrong is here
for representative McGee
and I apologize for not doing that
sooner
so now I'm going to ask the clerk to
call the roll on the motion of retain
for house bill 159.
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes
Larry gagne yes
Troy murner yes
Charlie Melvin
yes
Lex brezhny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
blochet yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Rosemary rung yes
Jackie creation yes it was just partial
yes Linda Ryan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Ned
Reynolds
yes chairman Bose yes 20-0 by a vote of
20 to nothing the committee votes to
retain House Bill 159 representative
McWilliams has volunteered to head a
subcommittee on this bill are there
volunteers to join her on that
how many do we need Jackie creation we
I have four
representative Summers could you be on
who's
well I already asked representative
Summers he agreed so
that gives us five with uh
now to clarify
because we retained this bill we can't
address it until
after the summer recess so any
subcommittee work will have to wait
until I think it's mid-august or the
18th of August something like that
so with that we'll close the executive
next
we'll open an exact session on House
Bill 458 relative to participation in
net energy metering by small
hydroelectric generators and I'll call
on representative Doug Thomas for a
motion thank you Mr chairman motion on
HP 458 is to retain
representative Bernardi second the
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we retain House Bill 458. representative
Thomas uh thank you Mr chair we've made
aware that there is a similar bill in
the Senate coming and we feel it is a
better version so we'd like to wait and
see how it comes out and so we can
retain this for later should should need
be
thank you in addition um one of the
companies affected by this bill White
Mountain paper has asked us to retain
this bill so that they can obtain a
better understanding of its Provisions
representative Wendy Thomas thank you um
just a clarification question if there's
a similar bill that's better why don't
we just itl this one are you just
because we haven't seen the Senate
version yet and we want to make sure
it's better before we let go of our own
version
okay thank you
further comment representative Krishan
just a clarifying question um do you
know the number of the Senate bill that
is similar
I do not but I know someone who does
representative Mr Cousy in the back of
the room please
incredible
okay Senate bill 40.
further comments on this motion to
retain
see none I asked the clerk to call the
role in the motion to of retain for
house bill 458.
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Larry
gagne yes Troy Marner yes Charlie Melvin
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
blochet
yes
James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams yes
Rosemary rung yes Jackie creation
yes I was just partial yes
Linda Ryan yes Chris munz yes Henry Noel
yes Wendy Thomas
yes
Thomas Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman Vose yes 20-0 by a vote of
twenty to zero House Bill 458 is
retained in committee
I don't see any need for a subcommittee
on this bill so we'll just hold on to it
till the fall and see what happens
with that I'll close the exact session
on House Bill 458.
a bill relative to the phasing out of
the minimum electric renewable portfolio
standard and recognize representative
Doug Thomas for a motion thank you Mr
chair on the motion for hb509 is to
retain
represent representative Bernardi a
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we retain House Bill 509
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
at the request of the sponsor he wishes
his bill retained uh he feels there
might be some work coming on down line
so to honor his requests that's why we
have the motion
comment on the motion to retain House
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the motion of retain for
House Bill 509 and remind members to
turn off your microphone when you're not
speaking
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Larry
gagne yes Troy Marner yes Charlie Melvin
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
blochet yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Rosemary wrong yes
lucious partial
nope
Linda Ryan yes
Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Gorman no
Ned Reynolds no
15-5 by a vote of Sixteen to five
fifteen fifteen to five the committee
seeing no
necessity for a subcommittee on this
bill at the moment will wait until the
fall to decide if that's uh
going to be required so with that I'll
close the executive session on House
Bill 509
and I'll open an executive session on
House Bill 81.
and recognize representative Thomas for
a motion
thank you Mr chair of the motion for HP
81 is to retain
representative Bernardi the second the
motion moved and seconded that we retain
House Bill 81 representative Thomas yes
we had a uh actually
Mr chair I have a point of order on on
for just the record uh it just occurred
to me before uh that we had a
subcommittee meeting we had a very good
discussion on uh the fees and the
subject matter of this bill but we we
did not take an official vote on a
subcommittee for a recommendation
so my question is should we take a vote
now so we can present it as a
recommendation to the full committee
foreign
that's not necessary since you did not
the subcommittee did not make a
recommendation it comes to the full
committee without recommendations so
it's up to the full committee to decide
what to do okay thank you for the
clarification uh so the the rationale
behind the retainers we we heard from
the the main speaker AmeriGas that they
were making several changes to address
some of the issues that were addressed
to us unfortunately the the the the
issues weren't very clear because we we
had stats on numbers of complaints where
there were many but we didn't have any
uh information as to or the data as to
to the the substance of of these
complaints and not many went to the AG
so we feel that by retaining this bill
it will give us the opportunity to
analyze and observe the changes that one
company is making to address their the
concern returns and was also give us
chance to investigate the other
complaints and to put some substance
behind them so that when we come back in
the fall to discuss this we can make a
better determination this place is the
onus on the uh on that particular
company to fulfill their their uh
promise is so it also gives us more time
to address some of the issues of the
complaints to see what their nature was
that was that's the rationale behind
retain this bill
thank you representative uh Rose Marie
rung has a comment yes thank you very
much much Mr chairman I was the Prime
sponsor of this bill and the intent is
to have a study committee so I think the
intent of retain is to study it more but
that's also the intent of the bill is to
study this issue more and I was hoping
that
um it it would broaden the people that
would be looking at this Beyond this one
committee I think a study committee if
this if the retain was to fail and we
went to OTP the study committee could
then comprise not only members of this
committee but also members of Commerce
and consumer affairs because I believe
some of the practices that were brought
up are really fall under their purview
we could also bring in through a study
committee members from the Attorney
General's office who've received some of
these complaints and consumer Advocates
so the intent of retain and passing this
bill is the same it is study the issue
my concern with leaving it up to the
industry to solve these problems first
is is a Fool's game because the major
company that is bringing these issues
has an F rating by the Better Business
Bureau it's on its second lawsuit with
the state of Michigan and has civil
lawsuits from Florida all the way to
Wyoming I don't believe they've
established the credibility to be able
to address their problems honestly so
therefore I'm going to vote against
retain and hope that emotion of ought to
pass would would then follow thank you
thank you representative Bernardi has a
comment
is as a member of the subcommittee we
also had considerable discussion with
the uh the Gas Association uh that deals
with all the companies in New Hampshire
and we got a commitment from them to
move forward on harmonizing some uh
Communications and I think it's very
important that you know we get that
feedback from them on how they are going
to operate
further comment on this uh motion to
retain representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair uh clarification question
of the subcommittee
um did you find issues with any other
um
there was a sheet passed out with the
number of complaints from various gas
companies in the state and uh the
AmeriGas was uh by at least almost two
to one uh more complaints than the next
company which was Eastern which had a
sizable number of complaints as well
but again they were numbers and no one
was able to ascertain if it was just a
complaint about billing if it was a
misunderstanding about a delivery day
was coming we did hear one or two
examples of issues with removing tanks
when you're changing companies but there
was nothing uh substantial with risk
those numbers that's why we we have a in
fact I believe this the Saudi committee
uh asked the question
the president I might forget who it was
but to go all fourth and try and find
out what those complaints subsisted of
and
I will say that uh if anyone was aware
of the retained bill that we had last
year I think representative partial was
part of the committee we as a retained
as a retained bill I will be holding uh
meetings to make sure that we get down
to the bottom of what's going on here
this is not a
this is not a brush off we will be
looking at this
thank you representative partial has a
comment
yes thank you chair
I was also part of that committee and I
think that's an accurate uh how Doug
represented we yet by and far the
business practice of one company
dominate these uh denominate our
hearings for the most part this small
what we call the Bob and pop gas
companies
they seem to be rather responsive to the
to the uh customers in their town and
they're well seated there I don't really
perceive much of a difficulty with them
but I am extremely concerned with one
player
and I really do think that a study
committee could give us the ability to
examine the how current these are and
what the options are and would put the
right people in place not those people
from our committee here but um people uh
legislators from uh consumer uh yes
Commerce thank you Commerce in order to
uh better serve uh the end goal um
and so that's why I'm going to be voting
against uh retain and for OTP should
have come up
representative Munn says a comment thank
you Mr chair I also will be voting
against retain for many of the reasons
that representative wrong
um spelled out
um I do think one of the significant
differences between a subcommittee and a
study committee is that the study
committee is required to submit a formal
report of its findings and
recommendations and my hope would be
that that report
could be a good road map for the
industry to follow and hopefully
Implement on their own
and you know it would also provide a a
sense of whether there's any additional
legislation that's required so it feels
more much more proactive and action
oriented than just a subcommittee
looking into whether we should in fact
have a study committee thank you
I would comment on Representatives
ammon's comment by pointing out that the
that retain and a study committee would
have roughly the same deadline to
produce results
and it might take longer to organize and
get moving a study committee whereas
this committee if we retain the bill
could move more quickly to get to a
resolution in time for a November 1st or
December 1st deadline
so retain and a study committee would
have the same deadline
but retain might get us to the end
result more quickly
see none I'll ask the clerk to call the
roll on the motion of retain for
Hospital 81.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Larry gagne yes
Troy Martin yes
Charlie Melvin yes Lex barajny yes Jade
Bernardi yes Tom blodger yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
Rosemary wrong no
Jackie creation no
lucious partial no
Linda Ryan no
Chris muns no Henry Noel
no
Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman no Ned
Reynolds No chairman Bose yes 10 10. my
vote of 10 to 10 the motion to retain
fails chair recognizes representative
Doug Thomas for a motion
anticipating this my emotion I make the
motion to OTP representative Bernardi I
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we OTP House Bill 81 any
representative Summers just a quick one
on the subcommittee although I made the
recommendation subcommittee for retain I
want to make sure that they actually
that the company that's involved
actually can move forward so I agree
with ought to pass as well
further comment on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 81.
representative Marshall
yes we recognize that Justice delayed is
Justice denied but I want to make sure
that we get to the bottom of this twenty
dollar service fee that one of our
members is being charged the quicker the
seeing now I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question about to pass
Doug Thomas yes Janine naughter no
Larry gagne yes
Troy murner
yes
Charlie Melvin yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure
James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Rosemary wrong yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Linda Ryan yes Chris munz yes Henry Noel
yes Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes
Ned Reynolds yes chairman Bose no I
think retain would be better
18-2 by about of 18 to 2 the motion
fought to pass
is adopted for House Bill 81
representative Thomas will write the
committee report is there any
need of a uh of a Minority Report that
was Doug Thomas
that was Doug Thomas yes okay
um
representative McWilliams just a
question for the chair is this a
potential bill for the consent calendar
yes without objection we'll put this on
hearing no objections
it's so ordered
with that we'll close the exact session
to an executive session for House Bill
and I recognize representative Doug
Thomas
thank you Mr chair recommendation for
for HP 558 the motion is to retain
representative Bernardi I second the
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we retain House Bill 558 representative
Thomas
again this is per sponsor request uh to
honor his request my motion is to retain
any further comment necessary around the
uh just like I don't have a sheet for it
in here
from okay oh no I found it it got buried
representative Christian has a comment
thank you um just to clarify request of
who to retain
representative Thomas mentioned
someone requested to retain can yes the
time sponsor Representative Keith Ammon
requested that this bill will be
retained
I am ready okay I asked the clerk to
call the roll on the question to pertain
Doug Thomas yes
Janine naughter yes Larry gagne yes
try Marner yes Charlie Melvin yes Lex
brezhny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom Leger
yes James Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams
yes Rosemary rung yes Jackie creation
yes loses partial yes Linda Ryan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy
Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Ned
Reynolds yes chairman Bose yes 20-0
by a vote of 20-0 House Bill 558 has
been judged to be worthy of retain by
this committee
and I'll close the exact session on
House Bill 558
and before we open the next uh exec
session we'll take a
five minute recess for
the committee to uh relax and stretch
who's who's fighting the uh on uh
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
certified
questions
six one six
Thirty-One
oh man
everybody
in my thought dad is looking into trying
to get rid of somebody
all right
so my motive was if we just we're gonna
do it no matter what
so
let's not debate it on the floor it's a
and Let It Go
you know I want to debate because it
makes sense
yeah yeah
foreign
ladies and Gentlemen please retake your
seats
okay let's resume our exact session and
I will put you all on notice that we are
going to
take our lunch break starting at 11
o'clock
and we will return at 12 o'clock to
finish the business of the day if we
have not finished it
before that and I don't anticipate that
we will finish it before that
the reason for the early lunch hour is
one of our members has to go present a
so we'll need to take a break for that
to happen so we might as well be
productive and have lunch and eat during
that that break
okay
pardon
if you could go find him please we'd
like to resume our activity here this
afternoon
so next
I'm going to open a executive session
for house bill 616.
and recognize representative Doug Thomas
for a motion thank you Mr chair motion
on hb616 is to retain
representative Bernardi is recognized
second the motion
it's been moved and seconded that we
retain House Bill
616 representative
this bill is relative to administration
of New Hampshire's renewable portfolio
standard and it's recommended it was uh
sponsored by representative
no McWilliams I'm sorry I'm sorry McLean
McLean Mark McLean that's correct Mark
McLean I am now I'm there I you know
representative Mark lean submit this
bill it had very interesting points but
we'd like to um wait and see what
happens uh down line uh uh the sponsor
would like to see something out of it
but but uh we we think that retaining uh
will allow us a little time to digest uh
parts of it
it may be worth studying later on we're
not sure but that's the main reason for
to retain representative McWilliams
each of those
um
there was a proposal as part of this
bill to add nuclear to the renewable
portfolio standard which I think is a
rather controversial move considering
that nuclear actually does generate
waste and so we're a little bit
concerned about
lumping nuclear as part of our current
renewable portfolio standard setup I do
think that there may be something to
look at if we retain this bill and so I
would support a retain but my knee-jerk
reaction would probably be itl so I'm
going to vote retain and for those
reasons
further comment on the motion to retain
house bill 616.
representative Summers
thank you Mr chairman I'm in favor of
retaining as well I know what they the
nuclear aspect ironically uh President
Biden just spoke in polling this morning
and said the United States is going to
start building nuclear reactors in
Poland so um I'm sure nuclear power will
be changing here in the U.S or possibly
soon
further comment on the motion to retain
House Bill 616 representative Doug
Thomas yes thank you Mr chair just for
clarification uh the subject matter of
uh nuclear was in terms of small-scale
modular which is a new safe small
technology and that is a basis of of
Investigation uh as opposed to the large
scale which we have no no desire for
I will not be voting in favor of
the motion to retain this bill I am all
in favor of small modular nuclear
technology coming to Market I don't see
that happening
within a decade and even if it did it
would be inappropriate to um
call it renewable and lump it into the
renewable portfolio standard as this
bill would so I'll be voting no on
seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the roll on
the motion to retain house bill 616.
Doug Thomas yes
Janine nodder yes
Larry gagne yes Troy Marner yes Charlie
Melvin yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi
yes Tom plouge yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams yes
Rosemary wrong yes
Jackie creation no
lucious partial nope
Linda Ryan yes
Chris munz
no
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas no Thomas Carmen no
Ned Reynolds no
thirteen to seven
I have out of 13 to 7 the committee will
retain house bill 616.
and we will decide in the fall whether
or not a subcommittee is necessary to
complete our examination of this
legislation
so with that I'll close the exact
session on House Bill 616 and now
we will open an exact session on House
Bill
622 and I'll recognize representative JD
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass and I offer an amendment
representative Thomas
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
judge hb622 to be ought to pass with an
amendment
thank you chairman uh in the discussion
that we had on this bill and the hearing
that we had on this bill
the largest concern was that we would be
shutting off the opportunity for for
people to have a voice uh periodically
with the with the Department of energy
and so working with the Department of
energy crafting Amendment
um that uh basically permits or requires
the department to at least on an annual
basis hold the meeting with a a large
contingent of
this pretty much the same folks that uh
that were in engaged in the previous uh
easy board meetings
uh the amendment is being passed around
uh okay so it's been moved and seconded
that we
amend House Bill 622 with Amendment zero
six zero seven h
hopefully you all have a copy of the
amendment by now is there any comment on
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
chair I think the amendment serves the
purpose of what was the basic concern
and it allows the department of energy
to hold
a hearing uh meeting I guess to cover
the same issues that were in the
easy board I plan to vote for that
further comment on the amendment as
submitted by representative Bernardi
representative McWilliams
I just want to note for the record that
the Energy Efficiency and sustainable
energy board was established in 2008 it
consists of 18 members representing a
cross-section of New Hampshire
leadership and it produces an annual
report
so this amendment basically does a
instead of monthly meeting from this
esteemed group it looks like there is a
once a year annual meeting with the
Department of energy to allow the public
to air their grievances but I'm not
seeing a report and I'm kind of feeling
like this doesn't really move the ball
forward on Energy Efficiency which is
the cheapest dollar we can possibly
spend the negawatt
where we reduce our energy consumption
by being smart about how we weatherize
buildings so for that reason I'm
concerned that this takes away the core
intention of the Energy Efficiency and
sustainable energy board lumps an annual
meeting with some people uh from the
public allowed to attend and voice their
concerns but doesn't really push forward
goals or report and for that reason I
would be against the amendment
thank you additional comment
representative Bernardi
yes as uh in reviewing the what the easy
board does and comparing it to what the
department of energy already does there
was a redundancy there there is a
requirement to have an annual Energy
report that looks at all the energy
Energy Efficiency certainly would be
part of that so the idea of starting to
limit the number of commissions and
committees and whatnot that we have was
the thrust of the entire bill and the
the concern raised was all right we
eliminated an opportunity to for folks
to have a voice well that's been
addressed by the amendment so I I
believe the principle
um
rationale for not moving forward and
consolidating activities has been
removed
representative Wendy Thomas has a
comment thank you I've got a
clarification question on lines five
through seven
um and I'm speaking as an instructional
designer now the department shall
develop strategies Concepts and tools to
enhance Outreach and education programs
to increase knowledge and awareness how
on Earth do you propose to measure any
I can answer that question as a member
of the current member of the easy board
the easy board has a subcommittee
that's charged with developing education
and Outreach programs and they have
issued an RFP
because House Bill 549 last year
allocated four hundred thousand dollars
to the easy board for
accomplishing the tasks described in
lines five and six
and they have issued an RSP RFP to do a
survey to find out what the status of
The public's awareness currently is so
that they can develop future programs
and tools to enhance the Public's
understanding
what this legislation would do
is
hand that task off to the Department of
energy the department of energy already
controls the four hundred thousand
dollar budget for this
procedure this process and so it's
it's unquestionably true that what
representative Bernardi characterized as
a redundancy in statute already exists
and this legislation would clear up that
redundancy by putting all the
responsibility with the for executing
this functionality with the Department
of energy since they already control the
purse strings
and furthermore it would provide a way
for public input into
a superior way to handle this process
going forward
as a member of the easy board I can tell
you that right now the easy board has
very little
power or to do anything and very little
authority
given the statutory changes that were
made last year in House Bill 549
the one
Mission or the one
task that they were charged with is
developing
the educational component and so this
simply moves that component into the
department of energy
and
accomplishes
the rest of what house bill 549 set out
to do which was to eliminate the easy
board
because it's no longer providing
an essential function
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
thank you Mr chair and as the
previous member of the easy board two
years prior to the chair I can vouch
with with his concerns having sat
through several meetings uh
that were basically presentations
um so uh I think the time and the term
of the easy board has been surpassed now
that we have the department of energy
further comment representative munz has
a comment thank you Mr chair
um what one of the benefits of the the
easy board as I see it is that it has
um members on it that represent
different constituencies including the
business community in the bill in the in
the Home Builders Association
and it's one thing to say that
um you know the department will conduct
a public hearing to to to which
everybody is allowed to come and speak
to comment on decisions that the that
the department is uh contemplating or or
quite frankly is already made
that's a lot different than having those
constituencies like the business
community and the builders be part of
the process of developing what the
recommendation should be
um and since you know they're the ones
that are going to be impacted the most
by what some of these proposals are
would make seem to make sense to me to
have them have a seat at the table in
developing those and as I can see it
right now the easy board is the only way
further comment
representative partial has a comment
thank you chair I would I would agree
though with representative moms
considering the current representation
of the easy board I welcome the
redundancy from what may be a very
different perspective
and which may not be duplicated by an
annual public comment meeting uh on
speaking of redundancy um yes just
agreeing that while we all
um appreciate the urge to get rid of
Superfluous and unnecessary meetings I
think that a single annual meeting for
public input is in no way um
sufficient for the amount of input that
okay any further comment representative
Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman yeah I want to say
that while I I do appreciate uh the
spirit of
um
representative Bernardi's efforts in in
crafting the amendment and and if I you
know take the
paragraphs five and six especially you
know on their face I think that's those
are really laudable goals but I I also
share the concerns
um that an annual
meeting with sort of one way
uh you know input a public hearing Style
versus the the collaborative
um
style of the
of the easy board function currently
um is wouldn't it wouldn't be
satisfactory I mean I I can definitely
see that
the need to reduce perhaps the frequency
of of easy board meetings from monthly
to perhaps quarterly
um but I I I guess I feel like this bill
goes even even if amended as proposed
would would sort of go too far
thanks
thank you for that comment since uh the
easy board has no real responsibility no
real Authority
whether it meets monthly weekly
quarterly kind of doesn't matter if it
really doesn't accomplish anything that
would be my comment
knowing that representative Bernardi has
to leave here in five minutes I'm going
to ask that he called the role on the
question of the amendment
2023-0607 h
Doug Thomas
yes Janine nodder yes Larry gagne yes
Troy Marner yes Charlie Melvin yes Lex
barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom pleasure
yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams no
Rosemary wrong no
Jackie creation no lucious partial no
Linda Ryan no Chris muns no Henry Noel
no Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman no Ned
Reynolds No chairman of Oz yes 10-10 by
a vote of 10 to 10 the
amendment fails I'll recognize
representative Doug Thomas for a motion
thank you Mr chair
a motion to retain this bill
representative Bernardi the second the
motion moved in seconded to retain House
Bill 622 comment representative Thomas
Doug Thomas thank you Mr chair retain
will give us the time to go over some of
the concerns expressed here uh at the at
this um
committee and um I think we owe to the
sponsor to put forth the best effort to
uh get accomplished what we want to get
done
representative partial
I could share
um I am starting maybe you can assuage
my uh concern but I am starting to uh
uh look at the number of bills that we
are retaining and it makes me a bit
nervous
additional comment
seeing rep representative wrong yes I I
have a point of order
um my notes say that there was an ought
to pass motion made and seconded and
then
um the amendment was presented and we
voted on that do we have to go back and
vote on that OTP motion
good question
I think that is correct
yeah we do believe that is correct
so and instead of discussing with
okay representative Bernardi is
recognized
Mr chairman I withdraw the motion to OTP
hb622
representative Thomas
second
yeah
I did we draw a second uh we draw the uh
retain
okay now you can make a new motion to
what point of order
yes
um so I guess now I'm confused
um we had a motion to ought to pass and
then underneath that motion we had an
amendment
since we don't we have to finish the
process because if the emotion had been
to retained we wouldn't have introduced
the amendment
well the original motion was ought to
pass
and then representative Bernardi offered
Amendment zero six zero seven H the
amendment failed so that returns us back
to the ought to pass motion as
representative wrong pointed out
representative Bernardi then withdrew
the ought to pass motion meaning there's
no motion on the floor so I'm asking
representative Thomas to make a motion
to retain I I understand that I I
thought we'd have to finish the process
and so the motion is to retain
representative Bernardi second the
motion moved and seconded to retain any
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
their motion on to call the roll rather
on the motion to retain house bill 622.
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Larry
gagne yes Troy Marner yes Charlie Melvin
yes Lex barajny yes Katie Bernardi yes
Tom plushie yes James Summers yes
Rebecca McWilliams
yes
Rosemary wrong yes
Jackie creation yes
delicious partial no
Linda Ryan yes
Chris muns no
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Carmen no Ned Reynolds yes
yes
15-5 by about a 15 to 5 the committee
and with that we will close the
executive session on House Bill 622 and
we will go into a lunch recess until
12 P.M
and I will see everyone back here at
one floor down
foreign
okay ladies and Gentlemen please take
okay let us resume our executive session
activity for this Tuesday
which I'm told is Mardi Gras day
so it's a day for us all to uh celebrate
I guess
all right
well we've all just had lunch so
Julie
all right
well
um
with that in mind we'll have some fun
so I'm going to open a public hearing on
House Bill 219 FN
relative to certain Public Utilities
statutes
and I will move ought to pass and offer
Amendment
2023-0461h and I recognize
representative naughter
I'll second sure motion Mr chairman
thank you it's been moved and seconded
that we adopt Amendment zero four six
one H to house bill 219. since it's my
amendment I will explain it to you
during the public hearing
it was revealed to us that the
rsas targeted for repeal in the original
legislation
where actually many of them were
actually needed and
instead of being repealed they needed to
be
re-codified in a different part of
statute
and that's what the study committee that
this bill created that's what its job
was to do was to figure out what bills
need to be re-codified and where
so what this amendment does is that it
took all of the rsas starting on as what
you'll see in the amendment starting on
line 20
and going through to
line
one on page two it moved all of those
rsas from the repeal section of the
legislation into the study committee
section of the of the legislation
the only piece of
the only statute that remained in the
repeal section was rsa's 376 a
relative to Transportation Network
companies and that
section was re-codified
in the original bill
in the proper place
that's uh now 350 RSA 359-u
so that's what the amendment did it it
kept that one section in the repeal
section because it's been recodified
already and it put everything else in
the study committee section of the bill
so it's a pretty simple Amendment and I
asked for your support and now I look
representative munz has a comment thank
you Mr chair
um I did I did look this this amendment
over and
um I think it accomplishes everything
that you stated and is consistent with
the concerns raised in the hearing so to
me it um
it it it's certainly something that we
should adopt
thank you additional comments on this
representative Bernardi it's a question
Mr chair did the other
department heads uh that had testified
and raised issues that they agree with
this have they seen it or or we just
wholesale he did it so it's you know we
don't even need to know actually the uh
one of the
I'm not sure if it was a commissioner or
one of the staffers at the Department of
Transportation called me out of the room
just this morning to tell me that she
and the department endorsed this
uh Amendment so yes the Department of
Transportation
and most of these RSA will rsas will be
recodified under the department
and they agreed with with everything so
representative Thomas thank you Mr chair
uh I agree and I totally urge everyone
to support the cheers Amendment
no comments
on the amendment
seeing none I'll ask the clerk
well representative partial thank you
sure both I agree with this passage as
well
so you know further comments I'll ask
the Kirk the clerk to call the roll on
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Larry
gagne yes Troy Marner yes Charlie Melvin
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
closure yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Rosemary wrong yes
Jackie creation yes lucious partial yes
Linda Ryan yes
Chris muns yes Henry Noel yes Wendy
Thomas yes Thomas Gorman yes Ned
Reynolds yes chairman Bose
yes 20-0 by a vote of 20 to nothing the
amendment is adopted I now move
ought to pass as amended and recognize
second
it's been moved and seconded that we
adopt
House Bill 219 FN as amended is there
representative McWilliams
thank you chervos I would just like to
commend you Mr chair uh for taking the
time to develop a really great Amendment
and also to do the work to review these
statutes that need to be reviewed so
thank you I absolutely support this
thank you I appreciate your comment
any further comments
saying none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of otpa on
House Bill 219 FN
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Larry
gagne yes dry Marner yes Charlie Melvin
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
blochet yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams yes
Rosemary wrong yes Jackie creation yes
Lucia's partial yes Linda Ryan yes Chris
munz yes Henry Noel yes Wendy Thomas yes
Thomas Carmen yes Ned Reynolds yes
chairman of Oz yes 20-0 by a vote of 20
to zero House Bill 219 F in
we'll go to the house floor with a
recommendation of ought to pass as
amended without objection this bill will
go on the consult consent calendar
representative rung um it has an FN so I
I think that's right good point thanks
for pointing that out so it can't go on
on the consent calendar so it'll go on
the regular calendar
seeing nothing further I'll close the
exact session on House Bill 219 FN
next
we will move to
and I'll recognize representative for a
motion
thank you chairman I move that we itl
523 FN
representative Summers is recognized I
second the motion it's been moved and
seconded that we itl House Bill 523
representative berezny
thank you during the testimony
um I believe the doe testified that
there's an open docket de
22-060 to study net metering and they're
against the bill because they would like
to have that docket finish and and have
the findings before we make any more
changes to net metering also last year
HB 1599 FN passed which which requested
the puc to do a study on net metering so
it doesn't make sense that we asked them
to do a study and then at the same time
make changes thank you
further comment on the motion to itl
House Bill 3 5 23.
representative partial
yes I see this bill is offering a more
immediate relief and considering that we
have
Industries in our state that are unable
to take advantage of economy scale by
having a five megawatt limit industry
such as an officer Bush who instead of
lowering their energy costs are forced
to make layoffs I see this is a relief
bill for those for those industries that
are troubled by it and I don't see any
problem because the one megawatt was an
arbitrary figure to begin with I don't
see any problem with going ahead and
passing this legislation which we heard
testimony could also potentially benefit
uh consumer rates I either see that the
well again Justice delayed is Justice
denied
I'll leave it at that
further comment on the motion to itl
House Bill 523 representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um during the
hearing we heard about the the positive
jobs impact of of raising this limit and
this bill was also described as a
business enabling bill
I just wanted to remind people of that
thank you
representative Reynolds is recognized
I'm
not in favor of
an expedient to legislate I'm in favor
of passing this bill the uh one megawatt
limit on the scale of
distributed generation that can
interconnect is a is a completely
arbitrary limit and it's a limit that
makes a lot of potentially
viable distributed generation uneconomic
because of
there's a lot of fixed costs to
developing any project into
interconnecting it to the grid
and therefore when all of those fixed
costs are forced to be
um
born by a a
generation asset that is arbitrarily
limited to a relatively small scale
uh it it makes it makes those projects
uneconomic for business to pursue
um you know one of the
desires we all have is to have more
distributed generation B
uh economic and be able to deliver
low-cost energy for businesses
and institutions and municipalities
um in our state and so
uh I'm in favor of expanding the limit
to five megawatts thank you
representative Doug Thomas has a comment
yes Mr chair just I have to agree uh
with the um uh
um with the representative brisney's
comments about the puc they are in
consultation right now with their docket
and anything we do now can just cause
some some confusion I I'm all one for
waiting to see what the puc does and
from there we can go on to do better
things but I don't think we should do
something now that's going to confuse
them later on
additional comment representative Gorman
thank you Mr chair uh yeah regarding the
puc I mean we're the legislature we have
oversight over them so I'm I'm not as
concerned about the puc docket uh but I
was also going to point out that during
testimony from um the representative
from IBEW Local 490 he talked about some
of the facilities in state already that
really could take advantage of going
over one megawatt uh you mentioned
Associated grocers in Pembroke
Anheuser-Busch and Merrimack a school in
Dover and and he said and I I this
really struck me that it would be like
giving a tax break to businesses because
it's lowering their operating costs and
I know that there's a lot of interest in
the legislature to giving tax breaks to
businesses this would have the same
effect
who would pay for that tax break though
that's the question
would you want rate payers to pay for
that tax break that happens in any tax
break right this the slack has to get
taken up or budget has to get cut for
but this is a hidden tax break that
nobody would see
just a rhetorical question
representative uh let's see do we have
any other comments okay yeah I'll let
you make a second comment
representative chairman uh no no I would
say in response to your your question
there
um that's the wonderful thing about
renewable energy as I mentioned in my
uh testimony
the fuel cost of renewable energy is
zero so
in making it more possible for more
people to harness more renewable energy
the the wonderful thing is that the
value
the additional value doesn't have to
come from others it comes from
from nature it's free for the taking if
we just remove arbitrary limits and we
allow again these are private investors
to build generation on their own
facilities with their own money
uh
and they're just harnessing the value
that is is available
to all of us thanks for allowing okay
additional comments representative
Thomas thank you Mr chair I would just
comment on that uh which was
um I think the question was asked in
committee here uh
there is no regulation that prevents
people from putting more solar out there
whatsoever
nothing
okay representative merner has a comment
yeah we've gone around and around with
this last few years and I had two big
projects in the North country and it is
free to harness and it is but these
people will not invest unless we give
them the give them the money so they
want us to pay for this through you know
to increase that one megawatt and I get
calls all the time on projects you know
they're not going to do it unless they
get that increase so they want they want
the rate pays to pay for their projects
that's and and to subsidize this stuff
so I'm in total agreement with uh
representative president
representative parcel had his end up
first
yes thank you chair I do believe that
our uh um consumer Advocate gave
testimony that these uh that this will
serve as a load reducer and doing as
much it has a very strong potential to
reduce consumer rates and I'm for all
for reducing the rates that our
consumers are paying
representative Christian has a comment
yeah it's just commenting on um I
believe we're referring to cost shifting
and I believe that the recent vder
report
pretty unequivocally showed that that is
not happening so it is not that these
projects are are costing money to the
ratepayers
we're simply
representative Bernardi had us a comment
I believe that vdr report said that the
amount of cost shifting was
not significant at one megawatt but if
you raise it to five megawatts
additional comment may I respond
representative Christian I'm considering
that that report came out before the
most recent spike in natural gas prices
I think
there's uh
impacts on both sides that we can
consider
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role in the question of itl for
Doug Thomas yes Janine nodder yes Larry
gagne yes Troy Marner yes
Charlie Melvin yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom closure yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
Rosemary wrong no
Jackie creation no
lucious partial no
Linda Ryan no
Chris muns no Henry Noel no Wendy Thomas
no Thomas Corman no Ned Reynolds nope
cherimos
yes 10 10.
buy about a 10 to 10 the motion to itl
fails
and I'll remind all members that if
there are no further motions made this
bill will go to the floor without
recommendation
having said that I'll ask the question
are there any other motions to be made
on this bill
representative McWilliams this is just a
question
um
having previously done this where we had
to vote itl OTP retain for every bill I
understand we're going to send this to
the floor without recommendation does
that still mean that the default without
recommendation starts with an OTP I just
want to clarify that yes it does that's
all I wanted to know okay
are there any other motions to be made
seeing none
will send this bill to the floor without
recommendation
James Summers will write the statement
for itl
who will write the statement for
representative partial will write the
statement in support of OTP
with that we'll close the executive
session on House Bill 252-523
and we'll open an executive session on
House Bill 524 the very next bill on the
list
and the chair will recognize Troy murder
for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move itl on 524
chair recognizes representative closure
I will second the motion it's been moved
and seconded that we itl House Bill 524
relative to Regional greenhouse gas
representative merner did you want to
say anything
I know that this is going to be
seeing the state of what we're paying
for energy right now would increase that
thing from a dollar to three dollars on
the money and it would be an impact of
roughly like seven million dollars to
the rate payers
further discussion representative munz
thank you Mr chair
um
the the impact on rate payers
um is would be minimal in terms of the
monthly impact
um I think we're talking about something
between you know a dollar and two
dollars at most
um and quite frankly the impact of that
would um you know not be not be felt if
the price of Rex continues to increase
as they have been uh we're only talking
about a two dollar increase in the
amount of money that would go towards
the um
renewable energy fund
uh so the renewable energy funds
the uh the the Energy Efficiency fund
um
which is minimal and as I said as the
prices go up uh the impact on consumers
is going to be
um they're not going to feel it at all
representative Summers has a comment
thank you Mr chairman
you know I find it fascinating I was
counting up how many bills that had been
through this committee that have been in
fact even tabled in the last session and
then we've been discussed here and every
time it's stated that well this will
only be one dollar two dollar three
dollars per rate payer and then if we
actually would take all these and pass
all of them including this one that that
little bit one dollar two dollar well we
expect them to get everybody okay fine
you're gonna pay 50 more a month sixty
dollars more a month what are we
actually looking forward to you get you
all keep saying that we're going to
raise it a dollar or two but it's going
up astronomically especially if we
passed all these
representative cretian has a comment
with respect many of these bills are
related to the same single dollar we
just kind of keep going around in
circles about where it should go
um
I obviously was in favor of the similar
Bill where we would send all of the
Reggie money back to where it belongs in
Reggie
um I think this would be a compromise
step to send a bit more of it closer to
what was originally there
um if we're really concerned about
reducing rates I think we have other
means to do that like the bill that we
did at the end of last session where we
were literally giving the money but
Reggie money is meant for Energy
Efficiency it should go to Energy
Efficiency thank you representative
Bernardi has a comment thank you Mr
chair well I'm also in favor of selling
sending all the Reggie money back to
where it belongs and I think it belongs
in the hands of the ratepayers all of it
what we keep hearing is uh you know a
nickel here a dollar here a dollar there
it reminds me of like Everett Dirksen
when he stood up in the house floor and
said
said pretty soon you're talking about
real money you know it just it's
unbelievable that we want to raise rates
on rate payers and I don't care if it's
10 cents or ten dollars it's
inappropriate at this time period
representative Wendy Thomas has a
just um we're in discussion um that
eloquent speech that we just heard about
not raising any rates but yet we just
voted on a bill to fund a study
committee for twenty five thousand
dollars so that seems to be a little bit
of confusion about that
um this was a bill the other day but
originally this bill was supposed to be
in law it was supposed to be six dollars
from Reggie was supposed to be used and
this bill asks for three dollars which
is a very conservative approach to bring
the action into compliance with what was
thank you additional comments
representative Reynolds at his hand up
yes
um yes notwithstanding the rhetorical
flourish from both representative
Summers and representative Bernardi
about us seemingly talking about adding
more and more money or taking more and
more money from rate payers we we have
been having the same debate over and
over in this committee about really two
funds which are the Energy Efficiency
fund and the renewable energy fund and
both of those funds of course are funded
by these small charges that have been on
a part of New Hampshire's energy policy
for over a decade and both are intended
to reduce to fund investments in
renewable energy and Energy Efficiency
that reduce customers bills and reduce
our dependence and exposure uh to fossil
fuels
I know that all of everyone on this
committee is hearing from their
constituents about their high energy
bills one of the first things out of all
of our mouths when we're talking to our
constituents ought to be
um you know
the energy costs come from the global
fossil fuel Market there's not much we
can do about that but one of the things
one of the first things you should do is
access the New Hampshire saves program
and
find ways and get financial assistance
in reducing your energy use and that
will reduce your energy bill people pay
bills they don't pay rates so you know
we I had a side conversation with
representative Thomas where he told me
that he'd referred one of his
constituents to the New Hampshire safes
programs and I thought that was great
and that's what we all should be doing
but when we underfund these programs
like we're doing with this one dollar of
the Reggie allowance money going to the
Energy Efficiency fund the program is
start for funds and when people reach
out and call it they are regularly told
oh the program's out of money for this
year you'll you'll have to you know we
can take your application now but you
won't
um you won't be able to access anything
for you know six months or nine months
so we shouldn't have that happening
especially in this environment we should
be funding the Energy Efficiency program
you know with a relatively meager
portion of the Reggie allowance money as
we've heard and and then referring all
the New Hampshire saves program is
hardly starved for funds its funds have
increased from 32 million to 73 million
since 2017. representative Doug Thomas
has a comment uh thank you Mr chair um
everything that everyone has said here
so far is true in their own way
um but I think more about the times
we're in right now and if you look at
all the money that Massachusetts has
thrown
against
um
their efforts to raise renewable energy
and you look at their rates their rates
they may be close to ours but they're
still a little bit higher so they really
haven't gained much ground in in that
but what I'm looking at right now and I
thought about this bill I thought about
the fact that maybe it's you know with
things where they are that there could
be some movement here but then I look
around and see where we are right now
with the high energy prices the high
electricity prices and I said this is
not the time to make this move it just
isn't
um we can talk about what it can do five
years from now but I think people want
to see what things can be done right now
for them so I can't support this bill I
have to support the itel and spill
representative Corman has a comment
thank you Mr chairman I'm looking over
my notes from during testimony and when
Mr Fontaine from Des was here uh he
pointed out that the savings from Energy
Efficiency do reduce demand and in
particular transmission costs because
that's that much less energy that
actually needs to be transmitted so
there are some savings that get spread
throughout the whole system
John Mann also talked about the
multiplier effect how how the savings
from Energy Efficiency goes back into
the economy so there are some some
impacts here that are you know
definitely positive impacts that that I
think we should be considering
additional comments
representative partial
yes thank you chair
we've had some of these policies such as
dredgy Energy Efficiency programs going
back to 2008 and the moment from the
moment they were conceived they're
immediately crippled uh by
and
and money was siphoned off in ways that
the original bill was that intended many
of my constituents know that if we had
invested back in those days in some of
these programs we would not be in the
state we are in today and most of my
constituents from speaking with them I
know they're happy for the few putties
paying the bill under the belief we're
going to be able to eventually get out
of the thumb of fossil fuels and as far
as Massachusetts and their investment in
renewable energies Massachusetts does
not set their only rates any more than
New Hampshire or Vermont do
is Old New England sets the rates and in
fact uh if rates are inflated because of
natural gas prices
it's States like Massachusetts and
Vermont will and who have initiated very
aggressive renewable energy policies
that end up paying for it more than we
do and
I just think that's really not
ah now
it's just not right okay thank you
representative mun says
thank you Mr chair I first want to
apologize to the committee for mixing up
renewable energy credits and Reggie
allowances
um we're talking about Reggie allowances
here and I I apologize for that and and
to representative Summers point I mean
we have been throwing around numbers
um you know quite a bit
um but as somebody said earlier those
numbers are not additive and it's
important to keep in keep in mind the
context of what we're talking about
based on the number based on the fact
that this would divert or or this would
restore about 6.5 million dollars uh in
funds to efficiency efforts and based on
the fact that we were we've been told in
previous testimony that there are about
757 000 customers in New in New
Hampshire that is equivalent to about 83
cents a month
for every customer and I think if you
ask anybody you know are you willing to
make an investment of 83 cents a month
with the idea that this will hope this
will help reduce demand and and and
increase the amount of renewable energy
so that we're not as reliant on fossil
fuels particularly natural gas which is
at a premium now in the worldwide Market
I don't think there's anybody in the
state that wouldn't say they they would
make that small investment of 83 cents
foreign
excuse me additional comments
representative Summers just a quick one
just to remind everybody that in when I
was here in 2010 on this very committee
um it was actually that crippling that
was actually written by the Senate to
save Reggie that in 2010 we actually
voted in this committee and in the house
to repeal Reggie altogether and the
Senate actually end up um
defeating that by actually setting it to
the one dollar standard if I remember
correctly
thanks for that bit of History
additional comments
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll on the question of itl for
house bill
524.
Doug Thomas yes Gene Nutter yes Larry
gagne yes Troy murner yes Charlie Melvin
yes Lex barajny yes JD Bernardi yes Tom
plushie yes James Summers yes Rebecca
McWilliams no
Rosemary wrong no Jackie creation no
Lucius partial no
Linda Ryan
no
Chris muns no
Henry Noel no Thomas or Wendy Thomas no
Thomas Corman no Ned Reynolds No
chairman Bose yes
10 10. buy a count of 10 to 10 the
motion to itl House Bill 524 failed
and I would ask the committee if there
seeing none
House Bill 524 will be sent to the house
floor without recommendation
representative Troy murder will write
the statement
in support of itl who will write the
statement in support of
so with that we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill 524 we have two to
oh I didn't check one off here oh I'm
sorry all right we're we are I was
correct we have two bills left to go the
next one up is House Bill 631 Dash FN
relative to electric utility smart meter
Gateway devices and I recognize
representative James Summers for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I make the motion to
itl this bill and I recognize
representative Tom closure
I will suck that it's been moved and
seconded that we itl House Bill 631 FN
discussion from the committee
representative Summers uh yes Mr
chairman I was uh
actually I'm an itl this bill and the
only reason why you all have heard of me
complaining about increasing rates to
rate payers or the cost of their bill to
the ratepayers and uh with this one it
was testimony by not only eversource
and then with the second by the
department of energy that in fact that
that
um the utilities would have to provide
um different models of metering as far
as actually
inventory which would increase inventory
costs and the inventory value and that
that actual inventory would be passed on
to the rate payers therefore my TL
further discussion on this uh proposed
legislation representative mines
thank you Mr chair
um I've been struggling with this and
and it's kind of a Chicken and the Egg
problem
um the
utilities can't offer consumers
opportunities to save money by
um
deciding when to
you know use power they can't offer time
of use rates without Smart Meters
um but
um without
um without the consumers paying for it
you can't have you can't have the smart
meters and and you know I don't know how
many consumers are going to be willing
to pay to Shell out 250 dollars
and it also limits the the the fact that
um the majority of households in the
state do not have these devices limits
what utilities can do in in terms of
innovative other ways to control Power
the whole area of transactive energy
and
so I've been trying to figure out is
there a way that we can you know somehow
get these meters in the hands of people
without
um
the individuals having to incur a
significant impact I did some research
and I've had some preliminary
conversations with the Department of
energy that there does appear to be some
federal
programs that would allow
utilities to pay for these me that would
fund utilities paying for these meters
um it's a it's a grant process that they
have to go through and I'm just
wondering if there isn't a way that we
couldn't spend a couple spend a little
bit of time here
recessing this this bill for a couple
weeks and just see if we can craft
something that would make some sense
that would get smart meters uh installed
in our state so we can begin moving
forward with some of these cost saving
opportunities
representative barajny is recognized
thank you chairman
um so my understanding is that this bill
is specifically for smart meter Gateway
devices and not just smart meters and if
I remember when um the representative
from eversource Justified he said that
um an example of a Gateway device is
just an appliance that knows based on
other factors whether it should decrease
or increase consumption such as a
thermostat for example and people can
buy a smart thermostat today that will
increase or decrease based on what time
of day and similar things so I think if
we're talking about Smart Meters that
that's probably a different build than
further discussion
representative Bernardi has a comment
thank you Mr chairman uh so
uh Mr locata from eversource sent me an
email I don't know if you all got the
same email but he answered some of the
questions that
he seemed to not have full answers to
during the hearing and one of them was
uh whether AMR and Ami meters have the
capability of of uh doing time of day
rates both do the differences Ami meters
have much greater granularity the AMR
meter is more of a yes or no type uh
meter
and then with respect to where ever
source is in Connecticut they are in
front of the puc to move forward with
the plan to
put Ami meters throughout the state of
Connecticut
representative Krishan has a comment
thank you chair
um so as the prime sponsor of the bill I
yes my intention was to ask for AMI
devices to be offered for a purchase not
that we want a resource or any utility
to necessarily be providing them for
free I thought that that was a good
compromise we did hear testimony that
some of our other utilities already have
quite a few customers on Ami devices I
think that it would be nice for
eversource customers to also have that
option
um but yes I agree with representative
ones that perhaps this bill needs a
little bit more work to to be finally
ready and I would
ask uh for your professional courtesy
and retaining the Bill thank you
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the role in the question of itl for
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine knotter yes
Larry gagne yes try Marner yes
Charlie Melvin yes Lex barajny yes JD
Bernardi yes Tom pleasure yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
Rosemary wrong no Jackie creation no
lucious partial no
Linda Ryan no Chris muns no Henry Noel
no Wendy Thomas no Thomas Corman
no Ned Reynolds no
chair of those yes
10 10. so by a vote of 10 to 10 the
motion to itl House Bill 631 fails will
there be an alternative motion
representative McWilliams
uh Mr chair I move that we retain House
Bill 631 and I believe I have a second
over there yes I would second that
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we retain house bill
631 Is there further discussion
representative partial
yes we definitely need good
modernization in order to take advantage
of such things as a time a day usage uh
smart meter would allow that uh if
there's potential money that could be
gained by retaining this bill and other
sources of that I think that the Suri
push on this the lower we can reduce our
Peak demands and the sooner we can offer
some real rate relief to our customers
our constituents for the discussion on
the motion to retain representative
Corman has it thank you Mr chairman
one other aspect of time of use that we
really need to be thinking about is that
we're going to be seeing more and more
people wanting to charge their EVS at
home as EV sales increase and this is
regardless of how any of us feel about
EVS what counts as how the chairman of
the board of GM and Ford and Volkswagen
and those companies feel about EVS EVS
are coming and people are going to want
to charge them they're going to be
wanting to charge them at times when the
rates are lower so that is going to be a
way that we can actually lower rates in
a significant way as people are using
larger amounts of power
it would be great if they could do it at
representative Christian has another
comment thank you um yes just one other
comment um in response to I guess the
assertion that needing to offer these
would force a resource to increase its
rates
um just want to comment that that's
always a choice that they make they
could choose to take it out of CEO
compensation or perhaps something else
we're not making them increase their
I'll make a comment here in that I think
that
we've we've already decided today to
retain 7 out of the 12 bills that we're
hearing
if we decide to retain this bill that'll
be eight out of 12 that's two-thirds of
the bills that we've heard today we've
retained
we had 40 bills in committee this year
if we retain two-thirds of them that'll
leave us with 30 bills to deal with this
fall
I think maybe we have we ought to
seriously rethink
whether we're doing the right thing here
by retaining these bills I don't see a
there are too many obstacles in the way
for this to become successful
legislation the way I see it
the department of energy
has indicated they don't see a path
forward ever Source has indicated that
they don't see a need for this bill
we've got the community power
aggregation program coming online this
spring where over 125 000 New Hampshire
customers will be getting their power
through Community power aggregation
and that organization plans to supply
smart meters to customers who want it
there just doesn't seem to me to be a
worthwhile path forward and so why
should we retain a bill that's not going
to go anywhere
that would be my comment
representative muns thank you Mr chair
um
it
you know there there is some some new
information that apparently there is
money available through the uh Federal
some of the federal bills that have been
passed
um it does require action on the part of
the utilities but
um I think there may be an opportunity
to get funding so that's one thing the
second thing is couldn't agree with you
more about the fact that we're retaining
so many bills
um and um you know but but we've honored
requests from other members to retain
bills we have a member and Prime sponsor
that is asking to retain this bill and I
think we need to be consistent and if we
decide not to honor that request then I
think we should go back and look at some
of the bills that we voted that we've
voted to retain based on similar
requests
I guess we'll all have to just vote our
conscience on this bill so I'll ask the
clerk to call the role in the question
of retain on House Bill six
Thirty One
unfortunately I think we're right that
we're retaining too many bills so I'll
have to say no
Janine naughter no Larry gagne oh
try Marner go
Charlie Melvin no Lex barajny yes
JD Bernardi no
Tom closure
yes
James Summers yes
uh Rebecca McWilliams yes
Rosemary rung yes
Jackie creation yes Lucia's partial yes
Linda Ryan yes Chris muns yes
Henry Noel yes
Wendy Thomas yes Thomas Corman yes Ned
Reynolds yes
13-7
5 out of 13-7 the committee votes to
and the number is now up to 8 out of 12.
I don't see any need for a subcommittee
on this bill at this time if we decide
we need one we can form one in the fall
so we'll close the public the exact
session on House Bill 631 and we have
one to go representative Wendy Thomas is
waiting on baited breath to get to
another committee room to testify on a
bill so let's see if we can get through
open an executive session on HB 161
relative to customer generators of
electricity
as group hosts under net metering and
the chair recognizes representative Lex
barajny for emotion
emotion that we itl HB 161 and I can
speak to my motion
chair recognizes representative Summers
I second that motion been moved and
seconded that we itl House Bill 161
representative bereshni is recognized
thank you chairman um so my reason to I
tell this one is the same as the
previous bill that I um 523 is that the
department of energy would like to see
the docket with the boc on net metering
completed before we make any substantial
changes and there was a point made
before
on the previous on that bill that it's
up to the legislature to tell the puc
what to do and in fact we did HB 1599
last year that we passed told the puc to
investigate updating uh the net metering
so I think if we told them to do that it
makes sense to let them finish before we
tell them to do something different
additional comment on the motion to itl
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman
um against the motion to itl 161 we all
got a I believe we all got a
email from uh Jim Monahan that was
helpful clarifying that this bill was is
not any kind of major change to
net metering policy it's really a
clarification
um or the correction of perhaps an
Omission in the past it's not about uh
allowing double counting no one wants
any double counting it's it's really
just allowing a facility that may
already be a net metering facility but
whose generation is much smaller than
its needs to also participate in a group
net metering Arrangement so that uh net
metering
distributed generation somewhere else
can help help meet its load so this is
just a refinement of existing policy
in my view thank you thank you further
comment
representative McWilliams
um I'd just like to say that the folks
who are able to take advantage of this
legislation if we were to pass it out of
committee are people who are dedicated
already to purchasing renewable energy
they probably already have solar panels
on the rooftop it's not creating enough
energy to completely run their household
and so they'd like to then take
advantage of purchasing from group group
uh solar elsewhere in the state and
they'd like to be able to do both that
doesn't mean double dipping it means
they'd like to have all Renewables so um
in terms of this as an alternative to
something like offshore wind I know
we've had some concerns that there may
be whales killed in the making of
offshore wind this is an alternative to
allow people to just buy their
Renewables from a group net metering for
solar thank you
it would seem to me that this bill is an
expansion of
group host net metering and the governor
has consistently vetoed
net metering expansion bills over the
course of the last four or five years I
think should this bill emerge from
committee successfully in and emerge
from the house successfully it would
never either get through the senate or
pass the governor
I think the the best path forward for
this bill is to Simply wait and see what
future net metering tariffs are going to
look like and we'll know that once the
current net metering docket is completed
and I think there's no need for any
change in net metering policy especially
policy that was likely to go nowhere
so you know further comment I'll ask the
Kirk to call the roll on the question of
Doug Thomas
yes
Janine nodder yes
Larry gagne yes Troy Marner yes Charlie
Melvin yes Lex barajny yes Janie
Bernardi yes Tom flocher yes James
Summers yes Rebecca McWilliams no
Rosemary wrong no Jackie creation no
lucious partial nope
Linda Ryan no
Chris muns
Henry Noel no
Wendy Thomas no Thomas Carmen no Ned
Reynolds No chairman Vose yes
10 10.
buy a vote of 10 10 this bill
s to achieve
a vote of itl from the committee
are there any additional motions that
need to be made from the floor
seeing none will send this committee to
the house floor without recommendation
and let's explore excuse me Lex berezny
well write the statement in support of
itl
and who will write the statement in
support of
okay
so representative Reynolds did you get
that we'll write the statement in
support of
OTP and representative berezny will
write the statement in support of itl
and with that we will close
the executive session on House Bill 161
and representative Wendy Thomas we got
it done by one o'clock
very much appreciated thank you
representative Thomas hang on a second
representative merner I think she's on
the subcommittee for House Bill 257 are
you pilot okay I want to meet next
Thursday at 10 A.M if that's okay I
discuss it with representative munz this
morning
I'll do it on Thursday because the first
three days of the week I'm tied up
is that okay and some Jim that okay with
you
good any other announcements from
members of the committee
seeing none I guess we'll see you all
tomorrow morning bright and early in
house Chambers for
uh this February 22nd house session and
again on the 23rd for another house
session so
safe travels home and thank you all for